you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news
on today's program global environmental
action a top priority as u.s
climate envoy john kerry becomes the
highest ranking biden administration
official
to visit moscow led light bulbs
smart appliances and hydrogen boilers
what the future
could look like in a net zero britain
and find out what it's like to spend
months on a ship
frozen in the arctic ice all in the name
of climate science
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show
where we track the changes happening to
our world right now
and we meet those coming up with the
solutions
now they're two of the world's biggest
emitters of greenhouse gases so action
on climate change taken by the united
states and russia
has huge implications for the rest of
the world today
u.s climate envoy john kerry is in
moscow
meeting russia's foreign minister sergey
lavrov ahead of the cop
26 summit in november well russia is a
signatory to the international paris
climate deal agreed by 196
parties back in 2015 but its climate
policies are
critically insufficient according to
climate action tracker
the country's emissions are the fourth
highest in the world
behind china the united states and india
but it continues to focus on development
and export of fossil fuels
mainly natural gas emissions in russia
are expected to carry on
at the same rate or to continue growing
until at least
2030 with the government's own targets
allowing them to increase
without missing international
commitments
yet the effects of climate change there
are stark
the arctic is warming twice as fast as
the rest of the world
and home to more than a fifth of the
world's forests
the country has seen two years of
record-breaking wildfires urban
populations are feeling the impact too
moscow recorded its hottest ever june
day
last month reaching just over 34 degrees
well with me now is our diplomatic
editor dominic
waghorn hello dominic and this is an
economy isn't it that's
deeply embedded in oil and gas revenues
it is but i think john kerry will be
going with a message that you need to
clean up your act for your own good
he'll probably point out that russia
is heating up faster than most of the
rest of the world two and a half times
uh the average of the rest of the world
that is leading to huge problems as you
say
forest fires huge flooding and also the
permafrost
flooding and that's doing things like
releasing methane but also anthrax
so there are real nightmare um scenarios
unfolding
in terms of environment in russia
already and the country is in the middle
of a heatwave so it's a good time for
john kerry to be going
there the good news is vladimir putin
seems to be noticing
this and worrying about it most recently
said in a speech that
mankind has got to minimize its impact
on the environment and the other good
news is that
uh joe biden and vladimir putin last
month kind of agreed to
agree on what they could agree on so to
set their relationship which has been at
a terrible low
on a more functional level it is huge
important for john kerry to make
progress there as you say russia
is has quite a small economy about the
size of italy's given the proportion of
the size of the country but it is the
fourth biggest carbon emitter
in the world so there's a lot of margin
in it climate margin if you like for
john kerry to
try and exploit there the bad news for
him is that vladimir putin has already
specifically said that foreign
governments
should not be using climate as a kind of
leverage to put pressure
on his own uh government his economy is
in a pretty polished state not least
because of western sanctions so it
doesn't kind of have
the sort of resources that might be
necessary to clean up its act
and the other bad news really for john
kerry is that actually climate change is
quite good for russia
in the north because it's melting the
arctic sea ice
and that is opening up that area to
exploitation for oil
and gas but also for shipping routes so
there's room for progress for john kerry
there
but i think he's going to have to manage
his expectations as far as to
what he's likely to get out of sergio
lavrov who he
he's meeting there delicate
conversations ahead dominic thank you
in today's other climate news severe
droughts hot weather and heavy rain
could all become more common in the uk
if global warming hits two degrees a
study published in the
journal climatic change found high
impact weather events will become more
frequent
and more intense as temperatures rise
severe droughts will become 86 more
likely
while snow days look less common as
temperatures below zero degrees
could decrease from 50 days down to 34.
greenhouse gas emissions from global
listed companies that could exceed
internationally agreed targets in just
six
years according to analysis by index
provider msci
it found many businesses would need to
drastically cut their emissions to keep
global warming
to 1.5 degrees above pre-industrial
levels
the analysis studied the climate
policies and disclosures of more than
9 000 listed companies
two blazes caused by lightning strikes
have combined to create the
largest wildfire of the year in
california
the fire which spans at least 134 square
miles
has been worsened by a heatwave the
second to hit
the northwest united states the extreme
heat has dried out surrounding
vegetation
making it flammable causing the fire to
spread rapidly
but an unlikely weapon being deployed by
firefighters comes in the form
of 80 goats by grazing on the tinder dry
grass in the region
these animals are helping to prevent the
fire from spreading further
protecting homes and wildlife there
well let's take a look at our data
dashboard now and the real-time
power mix in great britain essentially
where our electricity is coming from
well at the moment around 54
is coming from fossil fuels 26 from
renewable sources
and 20 coming from nuclear but if the
government
is to meet its target to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions by
78 by 2035 and to reach net zero by 2050
those numbers will have to change well
the national grid electricity system
operator has been looking at how energy
use in the uk
might change in the next three decades
they modeled four different scenarios
and found that the government's targets
can be met but only if consumers
embrace new ways to use power and urgent
action is taken
to increase energy efficiency measures
well joining me to take a look into the
future is matthew wright head of
strategy and regulation at national grid
eso
hello matthew just talk us through
what kind of things we all need to start
doing
over the next couple of years
uh good afternoon uh yes we we've
published our scenarios again this year
um as you say looking out to 2050.
um there are a number of key messages in
there but the one you highlight about
consumer involvement is arguably
arguably the most important
um our scenarios to hit net zero require
quite a number of lifestyle changes uh
we're all moving to electric vehicles
but we're going to need to have
smart charging of those vehicles uh
smart appliances in our house to make
use of our off-peak electricity
and there's even some changes required
to lifestyle habits
uh turning down thermostats and
obviously the stories that we hear about
changing our diets to some degree to to
reduce the amount of
red meat and other things that we eat
some of the bigger changes matthew
come at a cost don't they should the
government be
sharing in that cost
well i believe they already are so um if
we look at what's happened in recent
years
uh the growth of renewable power sources
for example offshore wind has been a it
has been a major
uh success story that's been driven by
the government providing
uh what's called contracts for
differences or subsidies to
to offshore wind in order to bring down
the costs of the that new form of
generation that's been spectacularly
successful i think going forward
we need similar sort of policy decisions
around
new technologies that would we will need
not least uh hydrogen
uh to replace uh natural gas for for
home heating
and indeed potentially for for making
electricity
uh and and potentially to fund energy
efficiency measures in people's homes to
bring
to bring up the thermal efficiency of
our housing stock
okay matthew wright good to talk to you
thank you you're welcome thank you
now in the latest in our series of
climate diaries
we're hearing from eliza droster the phd
student was part of a mission to take
the closest ever look at the arctic as
the epicenter of global warming
she told us what it was like to spend
months on a ship
frozen in ice
we had cake every single day
cake makes scientists happy and happy
scientists do good science
[Music]
the german icebreaker polar stern was
frozen
into the arctic sea ice and it drifted
along with the sea ice for an entire
year
scientists were rotated through every
few months
and i was on the final leg of this
expedition the arctic
ocean and especially the frozen arctic
ocean
is stunningly beautiful
there's this phenomenon where you have
some melt on the surface of the sea ice
and it creates these
beautiful melt ponds that have the most
fantastic colors of blue my research
um involved exploring the carbon dioxide
uptake of the arctic ocean
[Music]
how it changes throughout the seasons
and what it means
when we have less or no sea ice for me
this expedition was one
big epic scientific adventure
um it was really intense incredibly
exciting at the same time
it allowed me to personally experience
the vulnerability of the arctic
to a changing climate it's much more
impactful
to see this with your own eyes and
experiencing it with your own senses
instead of just seeing it in a graph
that's published
in a scientific article
an extraordinary experience and finally
cannabis
yes cannabis could be a possible
solution to climate change
hemp a specific variety of the plant is
being used to cut carbon emissions
in everything from fashion to
construction here's how
so
[Music]
well that is everything from us for
today next time
how fossil fuels could have a part to
play in a zero carbon future
find out how at the same time tomorrow
here on the daily climate show thanks
for watching